I live for you
I die for you
Forbidden Love they are rehearsing a
play about a Protestant girl and a
Catholic boy but for these young actors
religion matters much less than it did
in the past it was obviously a big thing
and it was a big part of your identity
but nowadays I feel like compared to
that it's just such a small part of your
identity we've kind of grown to accept
people more than what would have
happened in the past for who they want
to be and what their identify as like in
my friend group in school two are
Protestant to her Catholic and two have
come from elsewhere and at the end of
the day
we're all just people those pursuing
Irish Unity are encouraged by the
demographic shift but while Catholics
now make up 46 percent of the population
only 29 identify as Irish it's certainly
symbolic because the population balance
has never been like this but in some
ways
it's just the same instead of having the
Protestant group as being slightly
larger than the Catholic group and still
not a complete majority this time the
situation is just reversed the number
holding an Irish passport has jumped 63
the brexit impact and with 1 in 15 born
elsewhere Northern Ireland has become a
Melting Pot
the most telling thing about these
figures is that there is no longer any
group identified by religion or
nationality with a majority in Northern
Ireland and in that kind of diverse
Society it's difficult to see how
progress can be made unless politicians
are prepared to sit down together
Shelley lordy the drama coach behind
this production says her students now
appreciate how much has changed in
Northern Ireland we don't want to
romanticize the past we don't want to
romanticize the troubles but we need to
be very clear that this is where we have
come from it wasn't that long ago we can
never go back we need to keep moving
forward
um and to appreciate that Northern
Ireland is so much more than the tribal
politics
[Music]
it's now a pluralistic society many are
stepping into the middle ground and
turning their back on the politics of
division David Blevins Sky News in
Belfast